hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today we're actually
embodying that name for quite possibly
the very first time on this channel
because as I'm sure you're all aware
this world is currently facing some
massive very dark times and a lot of
people are being advised stay at home
which I'm sure for most of you probably
isn't all that different your regular
lifestyle I mean I for one am quite glad
to know that the technical term for my
own lifestyle is called social
distancing but as safe as that strategy
is it does bring with it some problems
such as boredom and general morale but
luckily the world of anime and manga is
here to help in fact providing an escape
from the outside world is what I believe
anime and manga does best and if there
was any silver lining to our current
situation it's that a whole ton of you
now have the opportunity of a lifetime
to delve into some nice deep material
and what I'm going to present you with
here today are ten series that you can
sink your teeth into
during quarantine lockdown isolation or
basic distancing and I'll tell you right
now most of these are going to be a
long-form series because that is very
much the point a short and sweet
experience is nice but filling time is
also integral to I believe they have the
correct candidates to do exactly that so
with that out of the way let's begin
welcome to the new world reviews top 10
quarantine series and sadly things off
we're going to look at haikyuu the
sports series to delve into which might
be nice because it gives us a chance to
live vicariously through the wonderful
world of volleyball now in regards to
this I must say that I myself was not a
fan of sports anime until I started
watching haikyuu
this pure gem really opened my eyes to
the potential of sports series with
impressively fleshed out characters all
of whom you will love to death and a
superb sense of drama far more than you
would think capable of a high school
volleyball club being able to generate
and the best part is if you went on a
volleyball fan don't worry you will be
IQ takes a very nice approach to the
sport itself introducing your viewers to
its intricacies gradually but also
managing to keep up a sense of
excitement and stakes at every level and
let me tell you if you are not on the
edge of your seat with your eyes wide
open during the climax of some of these
matches then you are probably just not
human so I highly recommend starting
with the anime which currently has three
completed seasons and a fourth one
currently airing but in addition to that
there are also 42 manga volumes which
equates to almost 400 chapters of
fantastic material to delve into and in
general provides a wonderful investment
opportunity for your newfound wealth of
time in this climate but next up we have
Hugh Harker show the classic series from
the early 90s also known as undisputedly
the best decade which very basically
follows the story of a delinquent
Yusuke who gets killed in an accident
but is offered the chance to return to
the world of the living by completing a
series of tasks ranting our charming
delinquent the title of unto well
detective
however from there you hunk show takes
some fairly incredible turns and becomes
a profound battle series and let me just
say if you like tournaments and this is
the series for you alongside Dragon Ball
Hugh Hawk show is well known for its
exploration of this format with the dark
tournament in particular being not only
a highlight of the series but a
highlight of my entire childhood I will
say this though because this is an older
shown and there may be aspects of it
that you might find a bit you know
trophy but YuYu Hakusho possesses such
an incredible nostalgic charm that any
of those issues very much fall by the
wayside and in terms of length this
series offers you 114 episodes with
almost none of them being filler which
is actually kind of shocking for a 90
Shonen but it leaves you with that nice
lean experience if you're more
interested in reading it though the new
Hulk show will provide you with 175
month chapters which while being less
than half of that if IQ is still very
sizable experience and one that you may
not have been willing to give a chance
in what was your normal life but now is
the time moving to number eight though
we have JoJo's Bizarre Adventure now
here is a series that I've only recently
gotten into myself because yes it is a
bit of an ask as it does consist of 126
manga volumes if you want to go down
that route however if you're more of an
anime person then we do have four
seasons a very well animate material
that covers the first five parts and
parts you say well it's not about well
the basic idea of JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure is that this is an
intergenerational anthology which first
follows man named Jonathan Joestar and
then goes on to feature his descendants
in a very strange journey through time
in which essentially anything can happen
and so each part will present you with
something radically different be at the
main character melded Jojo if you will
and even the storytelling genre itself
changes completely from pot to pot so I
am convinced that somewhere in this
massive material there is something for
everybody where the oh keen for an
action adventure in Egypt solving a
mystery in a small Japanese town working
your way up the ranks of a mafia
organization or just a good old jaunt in
the Old West and that's just a handful
of options that this will present you
with but I placed JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure here today because the length
of this series is one of the most
prohibitive that we are going to feature
on this list most everyday people after
a certain age simply do not have the
time to commit to an experience like
this but I would highly recommend at
least giving it a go and also not
judging it too harshly on part one just
give it the chance to get to part two
and from there
enjoy
this wacky quest to number seven now and
I would like to present you with dr.
Stearn Ohio Sakai good morning world
right so now for something completely
different and the basic premise of this
series is a mysterious apocalyptic event
has occurred on earth and almost 4000
years later a genius named Sen ku and a
selection of high-school associates
emerge from their stony prisons and find
themselves with the mammoth task of
rebuilding society and what follows is a
swift journey through human history from
the perspective of science and it is
enthralling and I want to make it very
clear that sanku is not your year ten
physics teacher as Sen ku is actually
interesting and applies his knowledge
with a large degree of entertainment and
traumatic impact and you will be amazed
at the kind of things that can be made
from scratch whether it be relatively
simple stuff like wander and gunpowder
or unimaginably complex tasks like
building a mobile phone now dr. stone
has blonde full anime season available
which is a great place to start but
following that there is also a ton of
further content to pursue in the manga
which I would highly recommend because
the art of this series is a marvel in
and of itself Boise is without a doubt
one of the finest ascetic craftsmen of
our time but more importantly dr. stone
is a fairly light-hearted adventure
which focuses on the power of humanity
to overcome any trial that it is issued
with which is probably appropriate now
more than ever but putting that aside
and moving it's number six we have a
Gintama so this series is quite the
Beast to get involved in so much so that
I have never come to a point where I
have fully consumed it but the basic
idea is that Gintama is a comedy set in
an alternate edo period of japan which
is currently under the rule of aliens
and i feel like the best way to describe
contaminoid very odd and in some cases i
can imagine that the series would be a
very acquired taste but hey we're in no
rush we've got some time to expand our
horizons with Gintama going on 12 you
are pretty staggering over 700 manga
chapters as well as 367 anime episodes
so that's certainly something to really
sink your teeth into
be aware that Gintama is primarily a gag
series that as time went on did develop
a decent dramatic aspect to it but it
very much enjoys the outer parody and
you will more than likely recognize a
ton of your favorite series at play at
some stage in this massive beast of a
property but once again the fact that
Gintama has a comic focus can only help
in these very serious times although if
you were keen to pursue something a bit
more on the dark side of the scale then
the perfect thing for you is coming
right up in the form of bizarre so while
everything else on this list has more
an all-rounder appeal here we are with a
young a more mature story to say the
least
berserk is what I would probably call
the king of dark fantasy it presents us
with an unrelenting ly brutal yet
marvellous world that is nigh on
impossible to take your eyes and minds
away from and a lot of that has to do
with its famed art which I'll say right
here and now berserk has the best art in
the entire Munk a medium period
Quintero Mira has this innate mastery of
light and shadow that allows this world
to become so tangible even in manga
format and actually for this series I
would insist that you stick to reading
the manga because berserk has had
something of an unfortunate anime
history but the first outing being the
1997 version which whoa it has an H well
and then there's a trilogy of movies
which you know are not the worst things
in the world but then there's also the
2016 anime which happens to be one of
the greatest abominations known to man
so it just really is a much better idea
to stick to the manga just be a whether
this world is cruel and unforgiving do
not expect a happy ending do not expect
any form of justice but do expect one of
the most legendary stories that the
manga medium has to offer but if going
that dark isn't quite your thing then
let's step back into the light with
number for being Gurren Lagann so here
is the shortest series I'll be bringing
your attention to which sits at 27
episodes but I feel like it's more than
worth mention here if you haven't seen
it and you know what even if you have
just go and watch it it's great Gurren
Lagann is a powerful experience began
acts featuring the story of two young
humans living underground who embark on
an epic journey that will consistently
blow your expectations away and I really
wanted to include Gurren Lagann here
because this series is optimism
incarnate it's wacky it's dramatic and
it's just plain inspiring to watch these
characters evolve and pierce the heavens
with their determination in life Gurren
Lagann is all about doing the impossible
seeing the invisible and most
importantly fighting the power and
honestly just just go and watch it it's
only 27 episodes and it may very well
leave an incredible impact on your life
as it did with mine but for something a
bit longer let's highlight number three
which I'm going to say is Naruto and now
here's an interesting one because I
would never claim that Naruto was one of
my favorite series in the world and
under regular circumstances I would feel
pretty guilty about putting someone on
the path of seventy two manga volumes or
potentially over 700 anime episodes in
regards to a series that I wasn't
entirely confident about but that worry
is no more right now and as much as it's
pretty popular to crap on Naruto this is
a
finding Chernin series about generation
and there is very good reason for its
global mega success at the center of all
of which is a young ninja boy with a
very simple yet ambitious dream of
becoming Hokage and from there we are
taken on a very long journey but the
whole host of likable characters
combined with a super schmick art style
there really is no reason not to read or
watch Naruto or at the very least give
it a shot I'm not going to claim that
it's the greatest thing ever because
they don't believe that myself but it's
still an undeniably fantastic experience
and one that will most certainly keep
you busy for quite a while to come and
if that doesn't take your fancy then
let's look at number 2 which is hunter
hunter and this one is probably less
than surprising given that hunter hunter
content pretty much completely dominates
this channel it's seriously just this
series already if you have not hunt and
it begins with the simple premise of a
boy who strives to become a hunter in
order to find his father but it becomes
so so much more than that this series
simply is not what you think it is and
it will shock you with the turns it
takes both in terms of plot and
characters hunter hunter to me is just
one of those supreme existences that is
so hard to compare to anything else
because it is incredibly unique and
given that it sits at 148 episodes of
the 2011 anime version which is my
recommendation to go on I think that yes
it is a decent time investment and
there's also a ton of manga material
that goes past the anime events so in
conclusion and anta just do it but my
ultimate recommendation is still to come
in the number one spot being one piece
so all of my life the one thing I have
consistently heard from people I've
tried to recommend one piece too is that
it's just too long and that they don't
have the time to commit to it well this
is a message to everyone I have ever
known which is that I need to tell you
right here now that you no longer have
that excuse ah and I've made a lot of
pretty big claims in this video and I'm
about to make another one because one
piece is pretty undisputedly the
greatest manga series to have ever
existed the anime oh that's a different
story it has its issues a lot of issues
so I want focus on the mark here which
follows a band of pirates each with
their own specific dream to accomplish
through a world that will completely
stun you in terms of both its size and
depth there has never been anything like
one piece before and there will never be
anything like it again it is a
monumental achievement of humanity that
is not only far and away the
best-selling manga series of all time
but also the third highest selling comic
series of all time in general and is
poised to take out Batman's number two
position in
so yes the art is a bit goofy and takes
some getting used to but when it comes
to manga one piece is the experience
that I would strongly urge you to give a
chance to and ninety-nine percent of you
will not regret giving it that chance
that I can guarantee but what do you
guys think please do leave your
quarantine series recommendations in the
comments below and if you'd like to see
more anime videos then feel free to
check out my other stuff we'll even
subscribe to the channel for a regular
anime greatness uploaded straight until
YouTube feeds but for now this has been
the new ultra view and I'll see you next
time